welcome back everyone 6
38 and metro sheriff joe lombardo
joining us now for today's morning cup
of joe great to see you sheriff good
morning
good morning alex how are you good hope
you're doing well a lot to get to here
in this segment we want to start with
that officer-involved shooting from over
the weekend
it was reported the officers were being
shot at in that incident can you tell us
a bit more about what happened and how
those officers are doing
sure i mean obviously it's still under
investigation so i could give you some
limited information
but we were called to the scene by the
female
person reporting we call him pr she was
concerned for a significant other he had
been drinking
a large amount of alcohol and making
you know aggressive statements i would
leave it at that
and upon our arrival we were able to
have the
family members exit the residence and
they informed us he was in possession of
some
firearms and he was
under out of control i would use that
term
so subsequently we responded and i'm
very proud of our officers because
the initial response was de-escalation
so
we surrounded attempt to make contact
with the individual
and he as you can see by the video he
came outside with a firearm
and he did fire upon the police officer
on several occasions
and then subsequently we returned one
shot
to the individual and i understand he
had a grazing wound from our shot
and eventually we were able to talk him
out of it so he exited the residence to
try to uh
jump over a wall in the rear of the
residence and we took them into custody
without further incidents so those are
the type of things we deal with on a
regular basis and
usually the public's not aware of that
those kind of
barricaded incidents are very common in
our valley
are yeah and that's chilling video to
watch sheriff
um another issue we've been talking
about it seems like for a few months now
a major spike in stolen cars up about 30
percent from this time last year
are you seeing this happening in a
certain part of town
yeah we are seeing it happening it's
closer to i think it's 28
in today's numbers um and it is not in
particular
to a certain part of town so it's
occurring throughout the town so
um that's unfortunate for us because we
can't put our
thumb on it you know in the short term
versus the long term but we are getting
a handle on that and i think the most
important piece on this is public
education
and awareness so the most common
form of theft is people leaving their
vehicle running and unattended so
such as going into a convenience store
to get a cup of coffee
or whatever they may purchase and then
people take advantage of that so
the most important piece is to be aware
of your surroundings
park in well-lit areas do not leave your
your garage door openers or other
valuable items within the vehicle and do
the best you can to make it harder for
individuals to steal your vehicle
and and the motivation behind it um
you know we can theorize that until the
cows come home but the
most important thing is is you know
people are going back to work
uh the availability of cars is lessening
and so
you're looking for transportation both
to and from
their heights it's very difficult
to put arms around but we are aware of
it
pressing it we're doing the best we can
sheriff governor sysolak signed two
police reform bills into law yesterday
the first one allows the attorney
general's office to conduct pattern and
practice investigations
and the piece of the other one limits no
knock warrants what are your thoughts on
those two
you know and i i got to be uh frank with
you on there
they're fantastic bills i i we worked
with the attorney general on those bills
but they're sort of benign to lbmpd
and the reason why i say that is i'm not
concerned about a pattern practice
investigation within my own police
department but
the need for the attorney general to
have that available to them is very
important
so we can determine whether there are
racist types actions conducted by police
departments or there's individuals or
even as a group they have to be able to
investigate that and that bill gives
them the authority to do that
and the cooperation is necessary
between the police departments and
attorney general
the other one was the no knock warrant
restrictions and that's where you have
a police agency or a group or a unit
conduct a search warrant on a location
and they don't knock at the door to give
warning to the residents or the
occupants
and they eventually use force to gain
entry um
they basically adopted our policy our
existing policy
with some negotiation work
warning we had that in place um
we haven't had any um incidents that
required us to
look at that in the recent history and
long history
but i think it's important for people to
know that that was a negotiation between
attorney general and local law
enforcement
and be coming to a consensus and what
would be better for the community
and protection to the community to
ensure we don't have an
unnecessary death governor you
sheriff rather you spoke recently about
a possible run for governor in 2022
you since confirmed that with the tv
station in reno earlier this week can
you confirm that with us
and why are you running you know i i can
confirm that with you
but unfortunately we
i kind of got caught off a little off
guard
up there in reno but uh you know that's
i gotta be frank with the public and
and and i am running for governor um we
plan on a formal announcement here in
the next coming weeks
and i will um display or provide my
platform uh moving forward at that time
we look forward to talking to you about
that then sheriff thank you so much for
joining us this morning hope you have a
great week
thank you alex if you have a question
for the sheriff you can send it to us on
our website
newsnow.com and find out if your
question was answered
every wednesday during morning cup of
joe i'll